12 مشروعا لثماني شركات كبرى بقيمه 192
مليار ريال تم اطلاقها ضمن الحزمه الاولى
لبرنامج شريك بما في ذلك خمسه مشاريع
لارامكو مع عده شركات عالميه بينها توتال
وجوجل وهيونداي بميزانيه تبلغ 62 مليار
ريال وكذلك مشاريع لمعادن والمتقدمه
برنامج استهدف فصول استثمارات الشركات
الكبرى الخمسه تريليون حتى عام 2030
الجانب هذا جانب التمكين اليوم اعلنا عن
مشاريع 12 مشروع لثمان شركات باستثمارات
اجماليه لهذه المشاريع ب 1992 مليار حصه
الشركات منها 122 120 مليار هذه المشاريع
لها اثر على
على الاقتصاد المحلي بحيث انها تدعم سلاسل
القيمه ويكون لها اثر على تمكن استثمارات
اخرى من ناحيه المضاعف الاقتصادي بالاضافه
توطن صناعات لم تكن موجوده في المملكه
تمكن صادرات وتركز على المحتوى المحلي
وتمت الموافقه في اجتماع مجلس الوزراء على
تحويل برنامج شريك الى مركز باسم مركز
برنامج تعزيز الشراكه مع القطاع الخاص
والموافقه على الترتيبات التنظيميه للمركز
البرنامج يهدف الى تنميه استثمارات القطاع
الخاص المحليه لتصل الى خمسه تريليونات
ريال بحلول عام 2030 كما يدعم توفير اكثر
من 100 الف فرصه عمل وتعزيز المحتوى
المحلي الى جانب مساعده القطاع الخاص على
المساهمه بنسبه 65% في الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي بحلول عام 2030 واضافه ما يصل
الى التريليونير الى الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي بحلول عام 2025
يؤثر البرنامج بشكل ايجابي وكامل على
الاقتصاد السعودي ويساهم في رفع ترتيب
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي للمملكه الى
المرتبه الخامسه عشره عالميا ترجمه لاهداف
رؤيه 2030 محمد زهير العربيه